historically in Miami when he was back  to Cleveland don't overreact we will not  straight pass by LeBron James inside to  angel who was cutting off with a couple  of days ago caldwell-pope James at3 got  it  it's five years since they made it  eliminated on the last day of the  regular season for two consecutive years  and Brandon Ingram in a nice blow  defensive player as he does here yo  could just force to commit to him but  how about for the Warriors in the Cavs  [Applause]  okay with the little floater inside  Yoga is gonna run for cover here's  [Applause]  and the players do  career he didn't have this kind of  confidence in their jump shot